she does need to reassert their
authority doesn't she we're told that
there is a reshuffle pending is that the
case I've no idea about any of that this
is speculation I'm determined to get
something based on an interview that she
gave to the Sunday Times well I think
you're here to explain what she meant
we all happen to be shot for the cabinet
in the next few we all have to be
careful about the words we use because
journalists like you will extrapolate
from any words that we use meaning that
may not be what was intended what she
said was she wanted the best people
around the cabinet table she's also said
before she believes she has the best
people around the cabinet table now
where they sit perhaps more thing is
that we come on let's be honest about it
if Theresa Meers to hold a reshuffle if
she is to re-establish her authority
there is one name that needs to be dealt
with and we both know who that is
there's a lot of ifs there you've said
Oh - it's at least in the question and I
think you - her continuing as prime
minister if she is to reassert our
authority through a reshuffle one name
needs to be looked at and again we both
know who I'm talking about here don't we
I think I think I know who you're
insinuating but I think the important
for us is that we get on with delivering
on what the countries are taught and you
talk about what people think in the
country I've been in my constituency
this week everybody first of all felt
incredible humanity for her but really
wanted to say that they cared about her
and they saw that she was struggling on
that stage on Wednesday we still not
feel sorry for her it's feeling that
anyone could be in that position I
suspect you go on occasionally and even
even you with a cold occasionally and
get through the show she did that to be
honest I spend my days in my bed but no
no let's stay on this topic of the of
the the reshuffle which you you're not
going to be speculating about but
seriously what does it say about to
these amaz'n if she doesn't move the
Foreign Secretary when it's not just
questions about you know the challenges
that she's made to his authority there
are some fairly fundamental questions
about his contents I wanted to show you
a quote that the Boris Johnson made
talking about a search they have a
brilliant vision to turn such into the
next Dubai the only thing they've got to
do is clear the dead bodies awake what
do you make of that well that was a
comment that he made as a fringe meat
conference perceivably trying to be
witty I don't think it was terribly
witty I don't think it was funny but but
it is incumbent on all of us it's more
than not with witty it's more than not
funny it is deeply deeply offensive when
I think of Sir I don't think of you know
that the Tudors amah portunities that it
affords I think of the images which you
will have seen as well of the lifeless
bodies of children being pulled from the
rubble of those the dead bodies no and
as I say it's incumbent on all of us to
remember that when we speak the words
that we use the words that we say the
comments that we make will be used they
will be recorded they'll be remembered
it's a very important life lesson for
all politicians I suspect Boris's
reflecting on that himself after those
comments if it were a first offence
maybe I would accept that Amber Rudd
describes him as a distraction I'd put
it to you with those comments about
clearing away dead bodies which have led
the Libyan Parliament to ask for an
official apology from the Foreign
Secretary of all people you know the
ultimate diplomat then I put it to you
if he's not a distraction he's an
embarrassment well as I say I'm sure
he's reflecting on the comments he made
and regretting that he even considered
making those comments never mind that
they were actually said but the
important point is that we get on with
the job the Prime Minister set out
policies in her conference speech that
we need to deliver on we need to get
that right deal with brexit but we need
to make sure we deliver on those
policies but when we identify the
injustice is when we identify things
going wrong we act on them